I still have this vivid image in my mind
I could see people falling down gunshots
I was so terrified really I was crying a
lot
someone who knew my father and my mom
grabbed my hand and he said let's go
let's go let's go and I was like my mom
my mom during nights who would hear
shots we would hear guns elections were
supposed to happen we had young people
go in the street they were having
strikes and most of the young people
died we boarded a vehicle it was
overloaded people were running for their
lives
that is how I a flee from Somalia my mom
l miss me nobody told her where I went
the fact that we did not go to school we
couldn't go to the market we were just
stuck home made me realize that if I got
an option to go for something better I
could just cover it and have a better
future
globally displaced people in the world
have been increasing now there are more
almost 60 million people displaced in
the world and unfortunately it doesn't
stop I think the humanitarian community
is starting to realize from research and
reality that we're talking about a much
more permanent problem these students
they need a tertiary education a degree
that they can use if the students are
living now in Rwanda if they get
relocated still they can continue their
study and still their degree is useful
whatever their
our audacious project was to really test
southern New Hampshire University's
Global Education movements ability to
scale to bring bachelor's degrees and
pathways to employment to refugees and
those who wouldn't otherwise not have
access to higher education it was almost
the impossible as a refugee person to
further my education and to make my
career my name is ADA inside and I am
from Somalia I was nine years old when I
came to Kakuma and I started going to
school at 17 now I am doing my bachelor
degree with SNHU my name is Maria Don
Brenda savvy Demi I'm doing my Bachelor
of Arts in communications with a
concentration in business we are serving
students across five different countries
Lebanon Kenya Malawi Rwanda and South
Africa really proud to have 800 AAA
grads to over 400 bachelors graduates
and nearly a thousand students enrolled
right now
so the magic of this is that we're
addressing refugee lives as they exist
there are no classes there are no
lectures there are no due dates there
are no final exams this degree is
competency-based and not time bound you
choose when you start your project you
choose how you're going to approach it
when you open the platform that's where
you can see the goals under each goal we
can find projects when you open the
projects you get the competencies that
you have to master directions and
overview of the project the secrets also
fascinates you is combining that
competency-based online learning with
the in-person learning that we do with
partners to provide all the wraparound
supports that includes academic coaching
it means psychosocial support medical
support and it's also that back and
employment support that's really
resulting in the 95% graduation the 88%
employment the social media management
intern it's related to the
communications degree I'm doing I've
learned so many things out of the
project and in the real world the
structured internship is really an
opportunity for students to practice
their skills and for us to create
connections between that internship and
a later job opportunity
this is a model that really stops
putting time and university policies and
procedures at the center and instead
puts the student at the center yes
energy model is a big way to shake the
tree huge is Ayub shake today - the
traditional way of having tertiary
education here it can transform the
lives of students from this vulnerable
and refugee communities if I get a
degree I can just come back and work
everywhere that I want I can go for
masters confidently in English which is
something that I would not have dreamed
of before and I have the confidence and
the skills required to actually go out
and just talk about the workplace
without having to fear that I can't make
it I always wanted to work with the
community I want to establish a
nonprofit we advocate for women
indication I want to be someone who is
like ambassador encouraged them to learn
tell them it is never too late it's a
dream
[Music]